i want to create a company and i want to
sell it for 100 million plus to walmart
or
amazon in three years what opportunities
exist
in the e-com world or in the commerce
world that amazon or walmart would buy
my company because they desperately need
something that i'm selling or some type
of solution that i've created
would you like him to do anything else
for you sam the most specific
question no that's actually not that
specific
i feel like i can rule the world i know
all right today we have mark laurie on
the podcast this guy is an og
of e-commerce he sold diapers.com to
amazon for like i don't know 600 million
dollars
he created jet.com and sold it to
walmart for three and a half
billion dollars good guy he came on and
uh me and sam
were pretty blown away like we kind of
little fanboys of his right now so
so we enjoyed the episode he had a bunch
of good ideas he talked about
how to go raise a bunch of money to go
after a big vision
he had some ideas in health care sam
asked him a great question like
if i wanted to start a company today
then i could sell for 100 million
dollars to amazon or walmart
what product would you recommend i start
and he had a fantastic answer so
he had ideas at the at the end and at
the beginning he talked a little bit
about
his kind of approach to why he bought
the minnesota timberwolves and how he's
going to run the team
how he builds his team how he hires
people stuff like that so
the beginning is more philosophy the end
is ideas and he also had a great
a great answer i asked someone like when
you bought the the basketball team did
you just like
send a huge wire um like just hearing
those details
are really interesting but we do a whole
long
debrief at the end of this episode which
you might even find more interesting the
actual episode because it's always fun
to like discuss
uh like i always find the recap to be
one of the most exciting so give it a
listen yeah but he was great i think
you're gonna love it and
we liked him so much we want him to come
back on one hour was not enough
and here's what we ask you to do um
listen to the episode
if you're liking it he said he's big on
linkedin so go to his linkedin
his name is mark laurie last name is
l-o-r-e
um and just go pop comment on one of his
linkedin posts and just say hey
if i like if you like the episode just
tell them love the episode
um come back on and i think if he gets
enough messages we will be able to bring
him back on and go deeper on a bunch of
ideas that we didn't get to do today
all right here's the episode enjoy um
okay cool
so we have a guest here sam do you wanna
you wanna team up
who's who is on the line yes so
e-commerce tycoon successful billionaire
and as of 2017
is exceptionally jacked in bulb mark i
have to ask you which of these is your
favorite part of jeff bezos
[Laughter]
sam's been polishing that one up for the
last hour
no uh mark lori we have um
mark you've done a lot of stuff you've
started four different things right four
different startups
that have uh successfully exited the
most popular one is probably
a few more that are in stealth that i'm
really excited about maybe i can share a
little bit about but yeah we want to we
want to learn all about it but
the biggest one was um jet.com that's
one probably everyone knows
uh before that you did diapers.com which
you sold to amazon for
550 million bucks ish that one might
have been bigger because that was sold
to amazon very early
and amazon appreciated a lot since then
so maybe that one i don't know you tell
us which one is which one ends up bigger
is it the early
the early one or jet i think no jet
definitely i mean
stock doubled uh over the last four and
a half years so that was
that was a good one i gotta thank you
for that when they bought you um
i bought the stock because i was like
yeah there's plenty of room to run here
for walmart e-commerce and uh yeah
i feel like i was a part of the company
i won a little bit as well just off the
news
and you um and then you also sold a
company called the pit
uh which is called the tops that was
like for 5.7 right back in the day
in the day and uh you prior to that you
were
you worked in banking but then before
that you were a runner so i was a runner
i ran the 200 meter and 400 meter what
was your uh
well i ran uh uh high 21's in the 200
and
uh 448 for the 400. same with me
almost exactly the same yeah high 21s
high 48s
exactly yeah i got slower as the
distance but longer and 400 was
was sort of long i was better at sort of
the 60 yard and
and uh and 100 and 200 but
yeah what was her 100 meter pr uh 1074.
wow and was that fat did they do 74 yeah
wow well that's pretty you're moving
i didn't have the endurance to keep it
up you know in the in the two and the
four but
yeah so so you've done a lot of stuff um
you've done you've done a ton of
research you've done
you've done a ton of stuff in the past
but even the stuff you're doing now is
also interesting you just
you guys made a bid for the timberwolves
right yeah we
actually it went through so we signed an
agreement so yeah
we're just going through the nba
approval process now and then hope to
close
like probably in like six weeks was that
a um a dream like you know i've had this
dream as a kid
you know own an nba team that's that's
the point of doing business
you know as a really small kid it was
like play professional sports of course
that's where you start
every kid you eventually realize okay
it's not going to be that sport it's not
going to be this first
you know and then i was like oh maybe
you know uh it would be
uh decathlete you know and go to the
olympics and i was like okay that's not
going to happen
i'm like all right forget it you know
what i'm just gonna like one day own a
team
that's what i'll do that's amazing that
was the dream you know
i was a huge sports fan growing up
followed every sport
watched every game you know it was a
huge knicks fan
and then you know i had two kids and you
know life happens and you sort of
get a little bit detached from sports
but i love it i'm excited to like dive
back in
and have a reason it's it seems like
back in it seems like
i don't know 10 15 years ago the sports
team thing was like
you've made it this is your it's like
buying a car right it's like i buy my
toy i always wanted this toy this is
kind of like lifelong dream and i think
it's obviously still like kind of a
passion thing
but also the business merits of buying a
team as an investment has actually
become a pretty big deal because these
franchises have appreciated like crazy
because there's only whatever there's
only 30 of them
and there's sort of more billionaires
and there are teams so
give me a pie chart is this what
percentage of this was just
i just want to have it it's like art
versus this is actually
a good business position how do you
think about that yeah it's probably 80
the former 20 good investment like yeah
it's it's not so much about being a
great investment just not going to lose
money
i'm going to have a lot of fun anytime
you can have a lot of fun
and not lose money like i love going to
the horse track
you have a lot of fun but you also a lot
of money
i kind of like this you know where it's
it's uh have a lot of fun and maybe make
a little bit of money too
it's like perfect but i'm excited about
you know just innovating using i think
there's a lack of like
real innovation in sports in general
like applying sort of a technology
mindset
like how do you bring augmented reality
to the
entertainment experience how do you move
to like dynamic announcing
so you can choose your announcer dynamic
real-time
ticketing i want people to move to any
open seat in the stadium at any time
like i've got all these like tech ideas
on how to
augment the experience and it's just fun
to have a platform to be able to
you know buy these things and try and
and even
you know what's the moneyball version of
of in basketball too you know like as a
mid-market
team how do you win what's the strategy
thinking that through uh
how do you uh apply the same techniques
of vision capital people like
what's the what's the mission what are
the values what do you stand for how do
you show up every day
how do you live those values like treat
it like a
like a real startup and and to date you
know i've talked to a lot of people
it doesn't really seem like anybody's
sort of
gotten gone down that path yet and are
you just gonna run this like a company i
mean like because you're
incredibly successful at running
companies but you don't i mean you know
a bit about sports i imagine but like
this is like a total this is totally
outside of everything that you've done
you've done e-commerce
i i love the challenge because every
business that i get into i don't know
anything about it when i start
i didn't know anything about retail and
i did diverse.com you know
i i didn't know anything about the pit
when i started that
i started a bunch of startups recently i
don't know anything about that i'm
starting and building the city i'm doing
a reality tv show
i'm doing these things and you know it
comes down to vision capital people
it's you have to have the vision and you
just think about it
share it with people like a piece of
clay you keep molding the vision molding
like wow this is a big vision everyone
agrees this is freaking huge
okay great how are we going to
capitalize it great that's
what i do raise money i have lots of
connections with investors that raised
over a billion dollars so like okay
we're gonna capitalize it and then the
third part is the most important and the
hardest to get right is people the p
part and it's finding a great ceo
and a great executive leadership team
setting the values
setting the mission the corporate
culture getting the org structure right
getting the right people in the right
spots and creating a culture where you
get the very best
out of each person that you bring in
then you kind of just sit back then
you're there as a strategic advisor
i think if you're trying to sit you know
micromanage and make decisions
um when you don't have the experience
that's where you get in trouble
you know so if i were to come into the
team and say you know i think you should
draft so and so and you know
why are we doing this and we should be
playing you know this and
that's not going to work i just don't i
think who is the very best
you know uh person in the world to
you know run this part of the business
to run that part of the business
to be the chief people officer to bring
in the very best talent and create a
great culture who are the best people in
the world
and get them in the right spots in the
right positions if the vision is right
and everybody's clear
exactly where you're going what what the
the north star is
and you've got great people and they're
happy and they're empowered
great things will happen and that allows
me to do multiple things at the same
time now because
you know i'm not getting into the weeds
of it a lot of your companies
um how much do you guys raise at
diapers.com
diapers raised 55 million okay
so that's a lot but not close to i mean
jet was
what like a bill i mean you guys raised
uh
yeah like 800 million so substantially
larger although though
both are quite large this idea of being
able to hire the best in the world
and being able to hide people hire
people to do to to do a lot of the
work that they specialize in could you
have done that if you were bootstrapping
your companies
no i mean that that's why you know we
started
alex and i um hey rod just started a
venture fund called vcp
vision capital people we believe that
there's a really big hole in the market
for people with big visionary ideas
to get a big infusion of capital early
like when they have nothing
so they can go out and hire the very
best team in the world i think a lot of
startups
it's a little bit of chicken and egg how
do you get the capital unless you have
the team
you can't hire the team until they have
the capital but you don't get enough
capital until you prove
it and so you get a million bucks and
then you get five million bucks then you
get
10 million bucks and each step of the
way you're sort of on a
tight wire type right you know you
you're basically like one little thing
goes wrong so the investors lose
confidence
where you under uh over promise and
under deliver
lots of things go wrong we basically say
no
vision capital people you have a big
vision we know this could be a really
big idea we know somebody's going to do
this at the right time to do it
let's not under capitalize it here's 10
million seed go out and hire the best
team in the world
that puts you in a position to have the
best shot of a really successful
business
if you got the best people you got the
capital and you have the vision right
you're a player now you're kind of like
worst case you're going to exit this
somebody's going to pick it up
because you've got great people and it's
the right time
it's a big vision so what do you what do
you think when
so there's there's the case where jet
where that clearly is what happened and
it worked and then you see like quibby
or something like that raised you know
clearly successful people at the start
raised a bunch of money raised a billion
dollars or so
more than that i think uh big vision hey
we're gonna
you know rethink netflix for mobile and
didn't quite hit it and they're burning
a lot of money so even though they
raised a lot their burn
still left them with i don't know how
many you know the same sort of time you
know two years of runway or whatever it
was that like a normal startup has
so how do you think about that do you
think it's hey look it's just a numbers
game it doesn't always work out or do
you think there's something different in
the strategy
that maybe they could have done or
you've done differently that that leads
to better results
yeah um i don't know that intimately do
you know
the story and i do think that's probably
more the exception than the rule i mean
i think listen startups don't all work
so some of them are
work do i think it had a higher
probability of working because it was a
big vision they had a lot of capital
great people yeah i think it i think it
does
specifically why it didn't work the only
thing from the outside
looking in was were the the
most talented people in the organization
fully committed an all-in to it that's
the only that's the only thing i wonder
i don't know
um obviously you had really talented
people but were they
dedicating their their life to it you
need somebody in these businesses that's
sort of like i'm running this business
and dedicating my life to it
it doesn't have to be necessarily the
person that's doing the vcp at the top
but who is that person and and and you
know do you have the
the right team to support so i don't
know the end of that that's where i'd
probably wonder
and so me and sam talk about this a lot
because uh you know we think about art
what's next for us we got
got some money in the bank we got time
we got you know we got all these dreams
about what we might want
to do and one of the paths is similar to
you where
you as an entrepreneur you sort of can
see these opportunities and you could be
you can be the spark that helps start
them but you're not necessarily going to
be the day-to-day operator in the weeds
maybe like you were with your
first startup right and um and some
people like you seem to be pretty
successful with this model and it seems
like it's
dependent on those three things you
talked about having the right vision
shaping that
first getting the capital in and then
recruiting the right people
on the people part take us into a job
interview with you
so um obviously there's the standard
stuff
you know you ask what they've done i've
hired
i've tried to calculate it but over a
thousand people right that
personally like you know interviewed in
my career and i've
honed uh over the years and it's changed
my thinking has changed on
hiring people resumes and i've i've gone
from
you know early in my career when i first
started you know i just want to feel
like i want to have a beer with this
person
right i realize how wrong that is and
people make that mistake today and at
least to all kinds of unconscious buyers
and things like that
it's the worst possible thing to do i
spend
an incredible amount of time up front on
resume reading
which i never used to do before used to
be like hey this person's great
oh they they were a cfo i'm looking for
a cfo you say they're great come on
interview them i i don't listen to what
people tell me necessarily about people
because
there's always somebody out there
that'll say something good about
everybody and so i kind of just discount
that
for the most part there might be a
select couple people that i really
trusted like you work with this person
trust me they're
they're top five percent okay but
that'll show on the resume and so when i
look at the resume
like i'm looking for a demonstrable
level of success in whatever they do so
i'm think i get into their mind i start
at the beginning when they graduate
school and it doesn't matter what school
they go to but
but they graduate they go into into a
company
um if if they're there for a few years
did they get promoted like what did the
trajectory look like
and then the most important part when
they leave that company and go to a new
company is it
something that a top five percenter
would do top five percent is move in a
certain way that you
start to learn machine learning these
these uh
you know trends um and top five
percenters top ten percentage of the
elite people
when they move they move in step fashion
it'll be a bigger title much bigger role
or
a better company and they'll get in that
company
and they will be promoted multiple times
and then they'll leave it'll be another
step
change and so i'm looking for that like
multi-company movement within the
company and
big step changes any kind of any kind of
deviation to that
i don't i just don't even won't even
interview so a lateral move out
right you know move from uh uh a google
to kmart sorry kmart but out like i just
i
anything any little like tap that says
not top five percent and somebody could
say hey but that's not fair
like i'm actually good or this person's
great i'm like you know what
i'm not going to interview because you
know what there's a chance i get honey
potted
right honey potted everyone's everyone
experienced this
you basically bring somebody in for an
interview the resume is maybe not ideal
they come in you spend one hour with
them and you just really like them
and they throw some buzzwords around
they've gotten old experience and you're
like hired
think about that i mean you're
committing to like hire somebody and
keep them in your company hopefully for
years to be an important part of the
company and like
you have an hour with them maybe you
have multiple people spend an hour but
still
a pretty small amount of time and so i
don't let myself get honey potted i've
been hunting potted
many times in the past and i unless that
resume
screams superstar which again it's only
five out of a hundred resumes if you say
top five percent or ten out of
ten one out of ten and be really like
say no
no no it's hard because you're tempted
like oh they have good experience this
person whatever
no so when i interview someone i know
that they're a superstar on the resume
and so i can focus
primarily on core values and they're
spotted traits so spotic is an acronym i
come up with for traits i look for in
people i hire
smart passionate optimistic tenacious
adaptable kind and empathetic
and the last two are really important
kind in
kindness and empathy i found over the
years that you can get somebody that's
super tenacious
passion they'll run through a brick wall
but also run through people
over people and they're not you find
somebody that has the passion
they're optimistic and tenacious and
adaptable because you need that in
startup
but at the same time they're very kind
and empathetic and you get that person
that's able to balance that
that's magic and so those are the
things and the interview questions have
nothing to do i want to ask one
traditional interview question they'll
all
be questions to open them up to to try
to get at
what makes them tick and do they exhibit
these traits
and you know i have this theory like uh
i've now if you work in tech you meet so
many smart people
that smart becomes kind of like table
stakes great yeah
everybody's super intelligent well now
what and and clearly
smart isn't just the only thing that
that leads to success you need a whole
bunch of other things that you mentioned
and um i sort of found like what's in
rare supply so which of those traits
is in most rare supply i'll give you my
kind of opinion which is
i found that two really simple ones tend
to be to me
the lowest in supply and uh and have a
pretty outsized impact in startups and
those two
are uh energy or like enthusiasm
i think bringing energy to the table
every day is quite contagious
and you need it at the beginning when
you're starting something from scratch
and so it seems like one of these anyone
can do it yeah anyone can do it but most
people don't and the other one is
courage
so the courage to either build something
new
uh say say something that's on your mind
um to like not let
you know something that's below our
standards go uh
courage i feel is in an extremely short
supply
take risk too right i call it boldness
we call it bull
at our company but yeah do you feel like
when you meet
people is there something you're just
like ah i wish more people had x what is
x for you that you feel like is in short
supply
you know i mean what you said there so
when i say you know passionate and
optimism
i think um optimism
isn't you know uh the sort of the
optimism that allows you to
be bold and take risk and it's that
optimism that you believe
not only great things can happen um but
also believe that people are good like
your starting place is that
it's just an optimistic view of the
world i think that's really important
and
it allows you to trust which is one of
the core values
in in in in all my companies i think
trust is really important if you want to
create a culture where
the company trusts the employees the
employers trust the company that's
really important
to create an environment where people
are happy and feel empowered
and they feel a sense of ownership trust
is so i have this
idea that you know a lot of people say
oh trust of course trust but verify
and i don't believe in the but verify
right i think you start out
trusting people um and until they prove
otherwise
and it's very risky because you can get
burned
but i've seen the power of the upside
of trusting somebody before they've
necessarily proven that they deserve it
it's incredibly powerful motivator
and i've seen it in my personal life
i've seen it in business people want to
they want to run through a wall for you
when you're like wait you trust me but
you can i can
burn you i can yeah but i trust you are
you going to burn me
of course not you know you're trusting
me i'm not going to burn you
that is an incredible value that i've
learned
it's it's trust transparency
being really open with your employees
not hiding not secretive
here's the cap table here's the rounds
of financing
here's the numbers here's all the
information you need this i'm an open
book
what do you want to know like there's no
secrets here you right work this company
you're an owner you have stock options
trust transparency and the other one is
fairness that
it's really important that people feel
in order to create an inclusive
a diverse workforce you have to create a
safe work environment where people feel
safe coming to work they have to feel
like it's fair
there should never be this feeling of
like that's not fair that's why
i have a open comp system where
everybody
knows what everybody else is making and
everybody at the same level makes the
same amount of money
so women minorities everybody makes the
same
there's no like this idea that maybe
it's not fair
my colleague why is my colleague that i
do the same job why are they making more
money than me that sort of thing which
is usually
a big reason why people lose trust and
they don't feel like giving you
everything they've got and so i kind of
take that off the table so those are the
three primary values so you have
the values of the organization how they
live them
and then the traits that you look for in
people you hire and when you kind of get
that right
i think it's it's a magical thing where
did this
where did this confidence come from
because like having the confidence to
hire the top five percent is a pretty
big deal
his high school track days sam yeah what
place your confidence comes from
it's actually just trial and error
failing a lot early on
it's it's you know you know well just
somebody i want to have a beer with
it's making those mistakes it's getting
honey potted it's uh
you know hiring a person and having go
through the pain of having to let them
go and replace them like
it's so many lessons i i i make so many
less mistakes now that i did
earlier in my career because i you know
i see everyone makes the same mistakes
that's why i like to talk about it
because it's like it is the same
mistakes and people say yeah you know i
guess you're right like there was
you know the resume kind of did but i
was kind of like well the person said
they were good i liked them and so i
hired them
um you have to be really um you know
like extremely focused and uh
selective in in that the other thing by
the way it does help with unconscious
bias too
if you're you know inclined
um when you go through the resume and
you bring them in and it's not about
whether i like the person you know you
they've already like you know that
they're they're rock solid and you
really can focus on
on spotic and sort of help there so i i
wanna
i wanna ask you about i mean i think we
gotta we should ask you about ideas
but but before we get to that i wanted
to ask one quick question
so you left banking in 96 right uh no it
was 99.
okay what and then i'm looking at some
information here on
on your timeline you started this thing
called the pit the pit was
a well it was it was in the internet
marketing
yeah it was basically a sports stock
market we used uh
to avoid gambling you know we used
baseball card as the proxy for the
athlete
but essentially it was meant to be a
sort of sport stock market where you buy
and sell players like stock
and you sold that for like six million
dollars yeah that was right after the
the whole nasdaq crashed in 2000. if you
guys remember like went down like i
don't know 80
or something and uh yeah
there was no way to raise any venture
money and we only started it
maybe 10 months earlier and we're able
we raised 5 million and sold it for 5.7
and everyone's like yeah
do it this is a great exit and we're
like
okay well then we'll do it again let's
that's great we'll sell this
and get the next idea that's what i was
going to ask you is how you could sell
for
six million bucks after such a short
amount of time but i guess
the answer is well because you you
raised a fair bit
at least for a six million dollar
experience just i think it was just you
know the
tops at the time was interested in in
the people that we hired we hired a
great team
we had a we had a vision for what we
wanted um
and they were there to provide some
capital
so yeah so let's talk about some ideas
that you would need optimism about
now right so uh so i think we could talk
about jet for example like
take some courage and optimism to to go
after that
prize and basically compete with the the
the empire of amazon
so but we'll come back to that i want to
start with where do you need to be
optimistic today what are you optimistic
about
what ideas are i know you've talked
about startup cities i don't know if
that's the one you want to talk about or
if you have some others
but let's shoot us some ideas of what
you think is exciting that you're
optimistic about that maybe the whole
world isn't
you know it's not not proven yet i mean
i
gravitate toward tend to gravitate more
towards b2c businesses business to
consumer i just like consumer businesses
and i think
it's easier to understand some of those
businesses than sort of
more like uh you know if you were like a
biomedical company or something like
that it's harder to
wrap arms around i think there's more so
most of the ideas and things in thinking
i do is
in the b2c world across lots of
different industries i've
made a number of investments uh and i'm
involved with a few companies i'm really
excited about
um one is archer which is the basically
they're like passenger drones
so i think i think it's like basically
an autonomous
uh electric helicopter um that basically
flies passengers you know around it's
it's safer than hell is this a spec
that you did yeah yeah it
did us back a couple months ago and um
going through the sec process now
that's crazy super exciting that was a
great
vcp um so the the two founders
you know came over it actually sit on
the couch right here
and they said we got this vision for
these flying cars these these
drones that carry passengers it's the
right time this is why it's the right
time mark this is how big the industry's
going to be this is why it's going to
work this is why the technology is right
and i was really taken by the vision i
thought they had it nailed
um and they said hey we need 5 million
now we're going to hire the best
engineers in the world we're going to
take them from the best companies we're
going to go raise 50 million and build
the state of the art the latest and
greatest of these
of these aircraft and i thought the two
founders were exceptional
so great start to the to the founding to
the p part of the vcp
and i thought okay i'll give them the 5
million and i'll help them
you know hire this this team and i'll
help them raise the 50. and then you're
on your own
right that's what we did i put five in
we helped raise
you know helped hire the the engineering
talent helped them raise 50 million
and that was two years ago and then they
just raised a billion through the spac
and so now it's a 4 billion 3.7 billion
market cap or something
and it was really an idea on this couch
two years ago but
it shows you what i was saying before
about rather than going through this
process of like
seed can't hire the great team the
chicken and egg thing
it's like here's five and then let's get
the team and simultaneously go and raise
50. so
right very short order they had 55
million dollars and they had the best
team
and i do think they've built the the
very best aircraft in the industry right
now and they're on their way like it's a
massive tam um and so i'm looking at
opportunities like that
um and i can tell you some other ones
too yeah i go
yeah yeah well another one that was in
the news is is
basically mobile kitchens so looking at
the trends in food delivery and
millennials and gen z not wanting to
cook and one food delivered and things
you know i just saw that you know it
sort of takes a long time to get it
delivered
inconsistent the quality suffers in
transit
and it's expensive and i thought oh if
you can solve those three things
um and how do you do it well what if you
cooked in a mobile kitchen if the
restaurant basically came to you and it
cooked in your driveway
hot much faster because the trucks
already on the road
and so they're they're likely just
minutes away
and uh and so i made a pretty big bet
uh on that company and uh you know it's
still in stealth mode but i'm really
excited about it
i think how how's that different than a
food truck so
so it's a mobile kitchen but it's for
multiple types of food or
each mobile kitchen is a different
restaurant different cuisine
okay um and uh the idea is to is to get
the best
restaurant of that cuisine in the
country and sort of bring it to a
central central place
you know it's high quality food that's
piping hot that's you know delivered to
your door
fast that that's an exciting i think a
big tam big market
food that's where the puck's going um
i think there's there's uh lots of
things lots happening now with
uh laws changing in sports gambling and
things i think there's
really big opportunities there to maybe
bring back some of what i did before um
what what what was that exactly
what you said you talked about the pit
yeah you said bringing it back before no
just
in in new now with the gambling laws
changing things i think it's an
opportunity to create a true
sport stock market and do it right like
where
it really feels like you're buying and
selling players like stock
um by by leveraging some of the changes
in
gambling laws have you seen uh something
i mean sean was really into this
big cloud have you did you see that no i
didn't you don't know what big cloud is
oh my gosh uh john you want to explain i
mean it's pretty much what it's kind of
what you're describing
um what they did was they basically took
twitter
and they turned it into a social network
where you don't just follow the person
you can invest in them so the cool thing
about this was what they did was
let's say on twitter i have like i don't
know 140 000 followers
so from day one what they did is they
took the top 10 000 twitter accounts
and they had raised i think 150 million
dollars from vcs here in silicon valley
and they used it to basically pre-buy
and invest in
all those accounts so on day one when i
walked in they said hey if you sign up
for big cloud if you claim your account
and verify it
uh like basically meaning you tweet out
that hey this is my big clout
i walked into like 75k uh
worth of my own coin right worth of my
own stock
and others were already buying it
because they were saying hey if sean
joins we think that he might
you know continue to grow his following
and so we want to invest so the idea
being
we've all had this experience where you
discover a band early or an athlete
early or
a content creator online a blog and if
you see them before they're huge but you
really like their stuff you can
buy their coin it's like every single
person gets their own little
little little bitcoin basically and um
and then as
they get as more people buy it yours
appreciates so as a curator as a fan
you get to sort of go along for the ride
along with the star themselves
ultimately because i think that's the
key a lot of these things fall down in
the end
so they don't have a ton of intrinsic
value they don't have a ton of
interesting value the one thing that it
does have is now as the creator so i
have all these shareholders right that
own my coin some people own tens of
thousands of people and a thousand
people 100 bucks in my coin
i can then basically reward my
shareholders so in you know in the stock
market you give out a dividend
or um you know that you you can reward
your shareholders
and this i could do the same so i could
say i could do it literally a dividend i
could say hey for whatever i earned this
month my shareholders are gonna
uh you know get get their proportionate
share i could also say
hey we're gonna do a version of this
podcast um that only my shareholders get
to listen to
right like like only fans or or these
different products that sort of say
if you if you're a subscriber of mine
then you get the content so you can kind
of pay wall of the content
dynamic membership almost like a
membership i can come up with
whatever the perks are for my members
and so then the creators all jockey
to offer better value to their holders
because their stock appreciates
the more incentive incentivizing they
make it now this is a one in a
hundred hundred a thousand idea but i do
think there's something interesting i
think there's something interesting yeah
it certainly sounds interesting i
i tend to shy away from things where i
don't see like the the the 20-year
30-year like the intrinsic value like
how
it ultimately this could be a great exit
and yeah
like i think with gambling uh
laws changing there's a way to give
players intrinsic value
so you basically basically say at the
end of somebody's career
i'm gonna pay you based on their career
stats x like and so you know
this rookie comes up you know like it
has real value because
the the exchange the stock market is
giving it intrinsic value by
giving you a predetermined amount of
money based on certain stats
over the career like that kind of that
that's interesting so you so you could
say
um so the house basically sets the line
right uh let's say
zion comes into the league and we say
okay the house believes the zion you
know the market the line gets set that
zion's gonna be a hall of fame player
and maybe that means x y and z stats
this mvp's this many points
whatever it is do you think it's better
than that right you buy
if you think if you think that's not
going to happen you don't buy are you
short and
basically the careers so you get to
predict the player's
uh journey and then the better than it's
like a super fan basically
as the better they perform you feel like
you're being vindicated and you're
actually going to economically benefit
from having identified somebody who's
going to perform higher than what the
market thinks that's cool
yeah exactly what um i i think i read
somewhere that you like to look at
google trends a lot like you're you're
and and because you're a serial
entrepreneur you invest in a lot of
stuff
you're always looking for trends you're
always looking for what's popular what i
want to know is
what what do you use like what signals
do you look for to figure out where
you're going to go to
and also what signal told you that jet
was interesting
because a lot of people probably said
don't even think about doing this like
you're you know you're i imagine a lot
of people are like amazon or walmart or
someone already owns the space what are
you crazy
this is like an impossible feat yeah no
it's
two different things i mean i think with
jet i'd been intimately involved in
retail you know with diapers.com and wag
and selling it to amazon and working
inside amazon
and i just felt like huge market huge
tailwind
it's the ecom's gonna continue to grow
at double digit for the next five ten
years um and
i just believed that there wasn't you
know it wasn't a winner take all that
there was room for
another player um and i thought we can
raise a significant amount of capital
and hire a great team
so we had this really big vision with
this tailwind
raise a ton of capital and have a great
team i thought if you do those three
things right
good things will happen i don't know
what's going to happen either it works
your exit
a strategic wants it like if you're in
the right market at the right time
you have a great team and you've
invested the capital wisely
you've got an asset that in worst case
is going to be worth more than the
capital you raised
that's that's my mentality with these
things um
in in anything you do right it's like
there's the worst place to be is sort of
in that no man's land
where like you you spent um
not a ton of money you don't have the
best people but you spend enough money
that is kind of expensive for somebody
to buy
as a strategic it's not really worth it
you know people tend to buy
it's the barbell strategy they'll buy
the aqua hire you raise a million bucks
and you bootstrapped it and you have
like three good people
and somebody will say like oh this is
great like here's 10 million he's like
oh that was like
not a bad exit made a little money i'm
gonna work for this company there's that
and then there's like you can uh be big
enough
to matter to a really big company
that has the capital to put down
hundreds of millions or billions in an
acquisition
there's a lot of people in like the in
the middle and that's what vcp is that's
why it's like no
10 million 50 million let's hire the
very best team if it's the right market
there's going to be a buyer for it right
and that's kind of the strategy
what's interesting is so when i sold my
company we never revealed the price but
let's just say that like
hypothetically it was like 30 or 40
million dollars
um i noticed that
i i just for a sake of argument that a a
deal
in that size it seemed like it was as
hard of work
as if i sold it for 400 billion dollars
you know it's harder that's hard
i think it's harder it was harder
because i was doing a lot of the work
i actually didn't hire a banker so i was
doing most all the work and it was
hell but it's not just the work on your
side i think what he's pointing out is
that the price tag is significant where
the company can't just cut the check
real quick
right like you could with a small aqua
hire but you don't have enough
of an asset that they can say this is a
big strategic bet that they're making
you're in the middle and i think that's
forget the entrepreneur's right it's
always hard as an entrepreneur really
tough place
yeah yeah well i'm saying that that's
just one of the reasons why it was hard
it was hard for many reasons really hard
you must be a really
good entrepreneur because it's really
hard i think to exit
in that middle ground like it's hard to
exit most companies in that middle
ground
they don't exit successfully you know
it's easy to do the aqua hire
and i think it's easy to do the big the
big acquisition of a big company it's
tough that's sort of like 10 to 100
million
and the entrepreneurs i know that have
exited in that in that space there
they're strong they're like really
strong
well so that's kind of an interesting
thing because i think that
me well younger like even just a few
months younger me
as well as most people would think that
well as far like if i could sell
something for 20 to 30 that's like bite
size
ish that's like uh you know some company
would buy us without having to get like
board approval like oh it'd be a
no-brainer for them to do it
and what you're kind of saying and what
i experienced a little bit is it's
actually probably easier to be a little
bit more audacious
yeah and raise money and go after it or
i would actually say the other way
around
it's easier to do that or in order if
your goal is to build wealth and have a
good life it's probably
best maybe not to raise any money uh and
never sell and just try to
build the company over a long period of
time but
let's say you were you um but you don't
have your brand name
right so let's bring you back we give
you youth but we take away your
reputation right so we're gonna take you
back you're 21
but you don't have the reputation uh but
you do have the same sort of mindset
that you have today you have the same
knowledge let's say
what spaces would you be going into and
would you also be
trying to do the same type of bet like
do you think you could raise the large
amount of money just through
charisma and hustle and vision uh
without having the reputation so
take us take us do it through a scenario
what do you think you would be
interested in working on or building
if you were 21 again today without the
reputation yeah that's a great point and
i think you know early on
and a lot of people i think share this
you feel like it needs to be something
like
really original or something nobody's
thinking about it nobody's doing or
something niche or like
and that's kind of what it is it's niche
and the venture capitalists are like
it's not that interesting you know um
and i've learned that it doesn't need to
be
something like niche or super inventive
it could be
just find a really big tam like just say
something like okay
health care okay and what's a really big
idea like where's the puck going in
healthcare
i would study where the venture
capitalists are investing what types of
companies i do the research like
where is the money going follow kind of
the money because that'll kind of give
you some idea of where
where some of these trends are right now
and uh you know with artificial
intelligence and telehealth and things
there's like a lot of money
pouring into that so just i would look
at the landscape i'd study
the different companies who's getting
funded who's doing well
and think about is there another angle
is there something not like
inventive or super original just like
just a
little hook of something different
that's not being done
and put together a big vision that
requires ultimately hundreds of millions
of capital
and work backwards from that and say
okay you know that we think this is
going to be a multi-billion dollar
opportunity
you know we're going to you know start
with 10 million we're going to hire this
great team
here's division here's how we're going
to get there work on that plan
and that pitch deck i'd spend hundreds
of hours on that deck
and on the vision and mapping it out and
somebody will bite because it's the
right time it's the right space
you know if you're really good and they
feel like you've got something
and you've got this big plan and you
know there's a good chance you'll get
that
you'll get that that 10 million dollar c
check
to go hire a great team and you talked
about you've talked about where's the
puck going
uh give us more what do you where what
are some other so you talked about
food delivery and you talked about how
what the next evolution of that might be
the restaurants on wheels that solves a
bunch of problems
you talked about transportation right
huge tam
flying cars that might be where the puck
is going we see that google funded
you know kitty hawk we and you know uber
was working on it a bunch of people
working on this maybe there's something
there
um i'll give you a couple more yeah so
one i think conversational commerce so
in retail
i think the next big step change is the
idea that you would
use text and voice to order
anything you want in a very
conversational way so imagine
you know talking to the to someone that
is
as knowledgeable as the most
knowledgeable person in that area on the
showroom
of a specialty retailer you want to buy
a tv it's like you're
there at best buy talking to the tv
expert you know
and you're just conversing and somebody
at the same time who knows you as well
is your
best friend um so hyper personalized
this idea of getting a one best answer
um
the idea of like search engine 20 years
from now is going to be laughably like
the cassette tape
it's like wait so dad you used to like
go you wanted to buy a toast and you
typed in toaster in this like
search engine you have 10 000 responses
and you had to like read reviews and
look at all this and search and filter
that's not the way it's going to be done
you're basically just going to say hey
i need a i need a toaster um how much
i don't know what's a good amount uh 200
bucks you get a great toaster really
good
okay great wanna make a recommendation
boom
buy it and it just ships it right like
it's gonna be very conversational and
the the
we talk a lot about personalization and
detail but nobody's even close
to doing it in a way that it's going to
be done in the future and i think
voice requires one best answer
otherwise voice doesn't work you can't
give you 100 things it's voice it's got
to be like
you know if you were asking your your
best friend hey like you know i know you
know toasters like what should i get man
you know like that kind of thing it
should be
very uh on point who's doing this now
that's exciting i like that
a lot what what companies are doing this
now i mean there's a lot of companies
that are
like again early stages of it and stuff
but there's nobody again that's
if you said who's got the world-class
team who's raised you know
significant capital you know nothing but
is there a
is there a product i can go look at and
be like oh i get it i
understand what he's getting at like i
understand why mark is obsessed with
this
yeah i mean we had something called jet
black when i was at walmart and we
um it was basically this for new york
city
uh primarily parents and it was
gangbusters i mean it was like
you know people stopped using amazon
prime it was they just dropped it it's
like
all the shopping the entire the entire
while chair
uh was was given to jet black and it was
multiples of what they were spending on
amazon it was deep into the tail it was
everything
people loved it and it was a great test
it was very expensive because
in order to get the comments to see the
conversations
um uh sorry you need to see a lot of
to have it automated so in the beginning
you have humans in the loop
to sort of bridge between the time that
you know right
there's the ai past tense did it go away
or that still exists
no it went away but it was expensive
yeah it was expensive and there just
wasn't the right time for walmart
right but i think if for in a startup
world yeah i think
i think it's totally different because
walmart maybe doesn't want to you know
invest hundreds of millions or billions
but a startup
totally different doesn't hit your
income statement everyone gets the gate
knows it you put capital to work and you
build something great so there's that
i think in healthcare too i think like
things i was talking about with
telehealth and all the stuff coming
together
i think the idea of like um people
taking control of their health uh with
home diagnostics and things
like there should be a dashboard that
exists you can look up i put in my name
okay mark lori
here's my dashboard i've got a number of
gadgets in the home
that i do on a weekly and monthly basis
like you brush your teeth twice a day to
take care of your teeth
what are you doing every day to take
care of the rest of your health like you
don't do anything
yeah there's all kinds of devices and
things you know monitor um
you know a little prick of blood and
monitor blood sugar
uh you know do the blood test once a
month get all your things in there look
at the trends of what's happening with
your psa do you have this issue
and then basically the machine learning
and through all the data
to be able to see like okay you should
see a doctor here you should do this
then
you should do this so here's the
probability of dying at this age
here's the you know here's the the heart
attack risk that you're running your
cholesterol is too high
if you get it down here's your
probability of heart attack comes down
like sort of make it more transparent
right now it's like this black box you
go to the doctor once a year
do some tests and whatever like it's
just kind of like a black box like oh
you know here's some medicine for your
cholesterol
you don't know what's what or why or how
it impacts your odds and like whether
you should be really worried a little
worried
no doctor will ever give you
probabilities about anything
there's no diagnostics it's like you
have to go to the professional
there's no home stuff i think all that's
going to change in the future
i do think people are going to like
really take control of their
their health in a completely different
way and they're going to be doing things
other than brushing their teeth to take
care of themselves on a daily basis
i just had a daughter and i feel like
when she's my age
she's gonna be like dad how are you even
alive back then you guys had
you didn't know what the hell was going
on inside your body now we have this
thing that we wear that tells me
everything that i need to know i know
when i take a bite of this
my blood sugar goes up or down and i
know like how stressed i am i know
you know i think it's going to seem like
cavemen how we
we operate today good there's got to be
certain things you get tested certain
times you know my daughter had celiac
disease
we didn't figure it out until she was
nine years old like that's i mean it's
not that
rare of a disease like some doctors
should have been like hey
here are the here are the things you do
here the probabilities of what's what
and you know these are the tests you
need
i was asking my mom my mom has celiacs
as well and she found out when she was
like
50 and um and she's like yeah as a kid
everyone was like oh i don't know you
just have an upset stomach all the time
she's like you know i'm a kid in india
i'm sure i had this my whole life
just like nobody ever knew and i was
like super i never gained any weight
because i couldn't like process any of
the food i was eating it took until i
was 50 when i found out
exactly everyone should have genetic
profile you know that gives changes your
probabilities based on genetics everyone
should have that
it should be you know tests certain
times that influence your odds and
probabilities and certain ways to
you know structure everything that's
just it's more organized like right now
it's not
organized i don't know if you guys feel
that i feel like it's not organized at
all yeah well
you got like uh like a whoop and then an
aura ring and i have a smart scale i've
got uh like a glucose blood a continuing
blue glucose blood monitoring i've got a
smart bed
uh like i've got like 18 different smart
things but they are
quite siloed but they don't actually
tell me the answer
they just you know like they don't
actually say like uh
th this is what this all means yeah
you know maybe they'll say like you're
extra stressed this morning sleep more
or don't work out as hard or your body
fat is too high
but uh it's kind of limited to like
pretty high level stuff
yeah it should it should be way more
structured you should have
be much more in touch with it like sleep
apnea is another thing
i don't know so many people struggle
with this they're like
all these things and the doctor doesn't
just say like
you know it takes a long time before the
doctor's like you should do a sleep
apnea study or something like totally
there
there's things you can have devices that
are listening near your bed that can
know it sounds that sounds like well i
always thought it was weird like
this a lot of cancers you can are cure
or are are okay like if you can get a
certain type of cancer and be perfectly
fine so long as you catch it early
enough and it's kind of outlandish
and archaic that like you can have a a
cancer and not know for
you know many months or a year it's like
what the
yeah you could have known this like
instantly you know
and that's kind of like crazy to me mri
by the way there's mri scans and you do
your whole body skin and like detailed
look at you know anything cancerous and
then stitch it together
every year you do it and you can see
micro changes and things
that exists now it's just not made
available to
you know the the people because of the
the cost of it but nobody even has the
option of even knowing that that's
available that i should do that
you could imagine like a system that
basically says hey
here's the probability of cancer you can
take this test
it's a couple grand it's up to you but
at least you know okay wait maybe i
should just spend the two grand because
it'll increase the probability of
catching it x number of years in advance
and i know okay it's healthier
no we just wait until we're sick like
you said with cancer it's like
all right now it's now it's you know
i like asking these questions because i
like knowing like what meets your
standards but basically
who in this space are you looking at
where you're saying that's kind of
promising is there any like one or two
companies
yeah i i don't i kind of maybe i should
more
but i i really spend a lot
of time just thinking about like
a complete sometimes sometimes i
if you know too much about a space it's
hard to clean
slate and invent because you're kind of
like get tied too closely into what what
people are doing so
i like the idea of just thinking about
it through the lens of a
of a consumer on what is you know these
trends are happening telehealth
ai you know these trends are happening
and then how do you stitch it all
together that's just thinking
sitting and thinking every day like
what's the big idea
and when it's really big you know
nobody's doing it and then you can
reverse engineer and go back and say
there any people that are working on
certain things that could be helpful to
it
but you got to go so big that you know
that nobody's playing there and that's
where i think the opportunity lies it's
like
yeah it's going to need billions of
dollars to pull it off you're going to
have to prove
it in a in a small area uh it's going to
be very expensive but then when you
prove it
it extrapolates out to a trillion dollar
business like
market cap opportunity
yeah yes i don't i don't i couldn't tell
you like
i'm not like tell you all the different
little components that exist right now
something that you said earlier was
basically you kind of like
reverse engineer a little bit from like
you'd be like i'm gonna find where the
money's going then i'm gonna build this
deck and i'm gonna
um raise money and then go build the
thing um
what's something that let's say that i
said mark i want to create a company and
i want to sell it for 100 million plus
to walmart or amazon in three years
what opportunities exist in the e-com
world or in the commerce world
that amazon or walmart would buy my
company because they desperately need
something that i'm selling or
some type of solution that i've created
would you like him to do anything else
for you sam the most
specific question no that's actually not
that specific
a lot i mean a lot i'm not i don't work
at amazon i don't know
100 million in three years yeah no i so
well you said one personalized shopping
conversation that's coverage i think
that's that's not
likely a hundred million that is like
way bigger or it's or it's not exist
like that's a little bit more binary i
don't
think a hundred million necessarily
impossible sorry i hundred billion was
just some
three years i think it needs to be
um a sort of a niche technology that
could
that's where the puck's going that's
going to be helpful to differentiate
it's going to be something
three years is fast so it's going to
have to be tech more than having
shown real market traction but it's
going to have to be a technology that's
probably hard to build that involves
you know ai the thing that comes to mind
would be
like fit analytics this idea that you're
going online and you're buying
um you know a address and being able to
see it
fit on you without having to get it
delivered to your home
you know return rates on apparel are 40
it's very expensive for retailers and
it's a pain
in the you know for people to buy stuff
bring it try it on
to send it back and things so the idea
that you know my body dimensions and use
artificial intelligence
to know the inside dimensions of the
garment to see exactly
how it's going to lay in my body without
having to try it on
to cut down return rates dramatically
there's billions of dollars that you can
save retailers there
and apparel is definitely um
an area where where there's a lot of
focus and um
like that's just wanting to off the top
of my head i love that that's a great
answer
that's a great answer there there's i
still i saw this guy in japan
um he's a billionaire entrepreneur and
like this is like his third or fourth
swing but he
created a suit that had these ball like
these dots on this black
suit and he would send you this body
suit for twenty dollars
and these bull these white dots on this
black body suit would
uh you know like in a video game where
they motion capture you yeah yeah yeah
yeah that's what it was and it would it
the camera was able to tell
uh differently than if it was you
weren't wearing this suit and he would
use that to try to upsell you on
proper fitting clothing i saw that it
never went anywhere
but i was like oh that's kind of an
interesting listen for every idea
out there there's hundreds of people
trying that's why it's never really
about the idea it's about execution
it's about vcp so are they under
capitalized
do they have the best team in the world
like
and quippy i know you said that in the
beginning but other examples of
you know big vision right time
massive tam like raise it a lot of
capital
and have the world-class team that's
like
all-in are there there's not that many
examples i could think of
in fact when i think of those examples
they're usually examples of things that
have worked that worked yeah i don't
experience that many times where
you have a world-class team ton of
capital
and a big vision at the right time those
companies get acquired because
mind was a good example of this uh deep
mind got deep mind it was an ai company
got acquired by google for 500 million
when
you know no usage yet it was just vision
and team and then i think deepmind they
said
that once they've plugged it in to they
do the fun stuff like they'll go beat
the best
go players in the world or the best
chess players in the world so they show
kind of its power it goes
flexes from time to time but they also
apply it to the google adwords um
machine learning and i think it's
generated like incremental multiple
billions of dollars already for google
just on the
slight optimization of adwords and uh
and then on the other side you have
magic leap where
magic leap would probably be the current
example of raised like a billion bucks
huge idea looks awesome in the demo but
they haven't executed it well enough
where it actually
works yeah or you could argue also a
little a little bit early
yeah at that same exact company like
today
going forward right could be totally
different game so
it is kind of interesting it would be
great to to map out vcp against
companies that have worked and didn't
work to see what the hit rate is
right sorry guys i'm realizing i have a
four o'clock yeah you gotta run
okay uh where where should people find
you if they want more
if they want more plug how few people
can follow you find you contact you
whatever you want
yeah i mean linkedin is is my primary
where i'm putting out a lot of
business advice and things like that so
i do linkedin i just recently
finally just launched instagram and and
start becoming more active there
but linkedin is probably the best place
right now yeah all right mark this was
great
thank you for coming on all right thanks
guys thank you it went way too fast
yeah it was good but uh it ended quickly
i wanted i had so much more we could
have talked to you i had so much i think
i think we should actually hit him up
and be like dude after after this
episode goes out
and he gets some love we should
ask him to come back because i need a
part two i had like five other things
i had so many i had so many questions he
was
it seems like he seems like a great guy
he his uh he ha
man he's really charismatic i get like
why i understand why he's successful he
would be dr he would be describing an
idea off the cuff
and i'd be like you know what this makes
so much sense i would like i would back
you
to the hills yes this makes sense uh i
could see why he's been able to raise so
much money
yeah he i asked that confidence question
because he just
oozes with that with charisma and
confidence so
let's talk about okay so first uh i
really love that coverage i thought that
was great i thought yes i agree
i thought he was great and i thought he
made for a great guest um
especially the second half his setup was
bad i cannot stand with people
i think he was talking to a cis on a
phone or a laptop with someone who's so
successful like he is
why do they not have awesome zoom setups
yeah it's crazy
to me uh but i think they're just like
on the go all the time so they're like i
don't even have like i don't even hold
my phone this woman holds my phone for
me
and uh you know i i just sort of speak
out loud i don't even type anymore
that's my
that's my uh uh bray who just said he
doesn't own a computer
was he i think he was that true or are
you just bullshitting in the chat
that's that's what i was told he doesn't
own a computer see that's what i was
saying dude i knew it i knew he's in
that ultra rich
wait so there's the mega rich the most
rich
is they don't own a computer nor do they
even touch a computer their emails get
printed out for them and they
either hand write or just say things out
loud and people go relay the messages
i think he's one notch below that or he
doesn't own a computer he just does
off his phone
that's weird to me i mean not weird
because i mean if you're a baller go
ahead
b baller ball out but like what if you
just want to type
a long essay or you want to or if you
want to
just clubs like us can't understand the
the feeling where you don't need to type
nothing ever or or you just want to like
search the web and like go and read it
like it just seems like easy to have
if you took my computer away forget the
work i would be so bored
i like need to like you know browse the
internet
yeah that's crazy so he doesn't own a
computer that's pretty cool
uh yeah the guy's awesome he said he had
a few really good ideas i
i wanted to ask him so he sent us these
notes ahead of time and he said this
thing about
million the the difference between a
million and a billion and i was like oh
come on i'm dying
we gotta save it yeah i wanted to know
what he what he was gonna say
i think we slowplayed it a little too
much at the beginning and just
as my fault i should have gone into one
of these but okay so a couple of things
so here's my takeaways here's my like
i don't usually do takeaways because i
don't think like i don't know
i just don't bother usually usually it's
not like i really learned so much that i
really want to do takeaways i was just
kind of entertained
but in this i actually did have a few
takeaways i thought
i'm just going to rattle them off
insight number one the barbell of
selling your company it's very easy to
sell at the small end and even at the
high end the hardest path is actually
that middle ground where
both of us actually sold our companies
and i think that that's true it feels
very true from my experiences and i've
never heard
anybody like kind of say it out loud um
so i thought that was
that was a good insight i liked that
basically
what he i i don't think you summarized
it or i don't think you said everything
basically he said it's easier
to sell a company for like he actually
said 10 million or under
or like hundreds of millions right
exactly
um and the reason why is you know the
small one you can kind of cut the check
just on talent
the big one you're buying like kind of a
more fleshed out asset
of technology or traction or talent
unique talent and in the middle he's
like you've usually raised enough money
where like your price your asking price
is too high for them to just
just do it without blinking but you
don't have enough
proof and enough of an asset that they
can like justify
you know a big strategic purchase and so
that's actually the hardest one
and i think he he was hinting at
something that i think is true which is
that entrepreneur who's done that is the
most dangerous entrepreneur
because they have enough money where the
next thing they chase they're going to
go bigger
um but they didn't get enough where
they're just satisfied and going to go
chill on the couch or on an island
somewhere
and um they've been through it but
they're not uh they're not done and i
think that that's what he was kind of
saying which is like
those entrepreneurs are the ones you
want to bet on i also when i invest
that's like a great signal to me is when
somebody has had a small win under their
belt
or a medium-sized win i should say yeah
i had um
andrew chen very successful asic's uh
andreessen partners said
some of the most he said the most
dangerous uh entrepreneur is someone
who's
uh somewhat wealthy enough that they uh
that they're
set but they have a huge chip on their
shoulder exactly and he goes
for example travis before he started
uber uh you know he had
red swoosh which was like a kind of tens
of millions win um ev williams before
twitter
you know he had blogger and you know
that's a good win but
you know went for more and there's a
bunch of examples mark cuban did the
same thing
right okay some other things i thought
he was interesting so his model
i didn't realize this beforehand but his
model is basically it's kind of like
moonshots
it's basically he's anti the traditional
playbook of silicon valley
which is raised in small steps so raise
a little bit of money
make a little bit of progress raise a
little more money make a little more
progress
raise more money make more progress he's
sort of like
find the biggest market you can go after
raise a bunch of money and go make the
boldest bet in that market for example
what he did with jet
he's like e-commerce huge market and
growing double digits
um i thought it was interesting he was
saying like you you know you don't need
this like
brand new novel invention it's like the
bet is going to be on execution
and you do want to have like a new hook
or like kind of like the 10 to 20
that's that's innovative but like 80 is
the same as
other players in the market and so he
was saying do that basically go raise a
big chunk of money
recruit the best people the best people
make great product
and then go raise a huge amount of money
to go for you know go for the
the home run shot and um i thought that
was interesting most people don't
use that playbook or don't talk about it
and that's like his specific
lane that he did as an entrepreneur and
he's doing as an investor i thought that
was cool
he also i asked him a question that you
laughed at a little bit but i thought it
was a great question
the reason i left it was a great
question and he actually gave a great
answer but you asked
like what's a company i could start and
in three years sell for 100 million
dollars to
amazon walmart it was like so specific
that i was like it's almost like
hey mark like i don't want to think just
tell me what to do and i'll go do it
like it was such a
such a solved my problem for me i just
laughed well
it was uh what was the word that you
said the other day or uh
orthogonal orthogonal it was my
orthogonal way of asking
uh of asking um what is a problem
that big ecom businesses have yeah that
they that they have
that what are problems that need to be
solved i'll paint that yeah that was my
way of asking that
you have a great answer he gave a great
answer the answer he actually gave a
previous answer where he
said something like a conversational uh
commerce
which is a really cool thing he'll
explain but the answer that he gave for
that
was uh oh uh fitting virtual fitting
yeah virtual fitting
so he gave a ton of really cool answers
and and the guy this guy
uh mark laurie who was the uh he started
jet.com which he sold for three and a
half billion where and then he was the
ceo or
uh president of walmart ecom and then
he uh before that he had sold the
company for 600 million dollars to
amazon so like his his his his
perspective is like about almost as
great as it can be yes
exactly um so i thought that was really
strong
and i liked um i liked some of his stuff
on the interviews
kind of like job interview side i think
i don't know how much people will love
that content because it's not as fun and
it's not as junk foodie as ideas right
but as somebody who ever
if you ever actually have to do that i
thought there was some good good
insights in there and
even though it was a little bit um
like safe like nobody can disagree the
things he was saying were
good um i didn't feel like it was just
cookie cutter like i think that i think
he genuinely believes it
and that's genuinely his approach um and
it matters a lot to him and i think that
came through during that part which is
cool because you always wonder like this
guy's doing this and this and this how
is he doing it well it's like it's
always
he's got great people underneath them
doing all those individual projects on a
day-to-day basis all right well then
how do you find those great people to
actually make the difference between
failure and success of the same idea is
having you know that great operator
underneath so i thought that was
pretty good what'd you think at that
part yeah i wanted to ask him more about
it but we didn't have time but basically
it sounds like he's not
totally in the weeds of his businesses
which is the way to go
um you know like if you can if he can go
i don't want to be in the weeds of
anything i don't want to be in the weeds
of my marriage
i don't want to be in the weeds of
parenting
the weeds are the weeds bro i don't want
to be in the weeds i only want to be in
the weeds
of the things that i want to be in uh
and when you start a company there's so
much stuff that you
think you have to do and it's cool i
wanted to hear his perspective of it
he's like look i have the vision
i hire the initial people and i raise a
ton of money and i just deploy that
money and make everyone else
uh specialize in what there's what they
specialize in
but we didn't get to ask him about it
well one thing he did show was
sort of like when we were you were like
how do you um
how do you figure out what that vision
should be and he talked about a couple
things he's like
i look at where the trends are where's
the puck going right he's like one way i
do that
is i see where investors are pouring in
money okay that tells me that these
spaces are probably big or these
technologies are breakthrough
technologies
and so it's either like a technology
like ai machine learning okay cool i can
apply that in another
industry or everything's a bunch of
people pouring money into e-commerce
okay e-commerce is probably really big
or education healthcare is really big
all right that's a big space now how do
i go create the most bold vision that
has like you know a slightly novel hook
and i thought it was cool that he was
basically like i don't get bogged down
in the in kind of the details of like
what is this player doing versus this
player versus this player
he's just sort of like how should it be
right when he was talking about
healthcare he's like i should just wake
up
i have a dashboard that says here's
what's going on in your body and it
recommends
that hey you should get this checked
with a doctor or you should improve this
and um and i thought the kind of like
just from a mind of a customer
instead of like industry research i
thought yeah
better that's a big amazonian thing to
do is is that which is like
you just start with the customer and you
say here's how their life should be
that would make them really happy all
right now i have a pleased customer now
i'll go figure out how to make that
happen
instead of the other way around which is
what can i do and then uh
does that partially satisfy customer
okay that's good enough and i wanted to
ask him about air uh
about amazon and working with bezos and
things like that i
i wonder what his opinion will be buying
the timberwolves i feel like there's
more we could do there because he bought
a sports team
you know one thing this is a crazy story
that i'll just share here i didn't get
to bring it up with him but
but uh ben found this when he was doing
some research for this
was he he goes um
with when jet was when jet was growing
or early on with jet
they had a contest i don't know if
you've seen this this article but
a contest about um who can acquire the
most customers for jet you become a
marketer you you
go spread the word whoever whoever does
whoever gets the most customers gets a
hundred thousand shares of jet
and some guy went and did it and he he
basically just did like kind of like
paid marketing
in a unique way he spent eight the guy
invested eighteen thousand dollars into
the paid marketing
won the contest and his hundred thousand
shares became worth 20 million when it
sold
and so this guy turned 18 grand and did
20 million as a fan of the company
outside the company probably made more
than anyone else in the company besides
mark
which is amazing to me i remember that
story and
i was one of those people trying to uh
this was like you participated in this
oh definitely you didn't you didn't
participate like if you were just it was
basically
so robin hood did a good job of this uh
i believe it was robin hood
um clubhouse has done a pretty good job
but like basically robin hood's
campaign right before they launched was
you're on the waiting list refer five
people to move up the spot
right uh this was jet's version of that
although jet
was first i believe uh then robin before
robin hood
and it went incredibly viral if i
remember correctly i think they had
billboards promoting this
the contest yeah do you remember that uh
when you would i think
we should have asked him about this all
right we'll save this one for next time
but i thought
this is an amazing story yeah i could
spend about two more hours with him
easily
so i hope he comes back let us know in
the reviews what you think oh
quick update uh we're going to miami
i think in uh eight days or something
june
4th uh we sold 300 tickets
uh that's great i think we have we have
a few left right we're releasing maybe
what
80 more hundred more something like that
yeah we moved it to uh 400 it was 300 we
moved it to 400.
um we'll see what happens all right if
you want to come see us if you want us
to autograph your dollar bills bring
them to miami
uh june 4th uh i don't know how they
should find the eventbrite
just go to uh mfmpot or
myfirstmillionpod.mfmpod.com
uh and put in your email we'll email you
the details right
yeah and there'll be a link on there if
you go to mfnpod.com
and also if you just follow one of us on
twitter you could definitely see the
links where
we're promoting it and do us a favor if
you liked this episode with mark
when we post it um we're going to post
it i don't know
i guess go on linkedin and we i want to
shower him with love of people being
like dude this was great come back on
and then he'll come back on so we'll we
need to game linkedin a little bit i
might have to dust off the old linkedin
password to go and uh and because that's
the thing when guests come on
they i've consistently heard this from
the very beginning of this podcast which
is
dude i get way more messages about this
podcast than any other podcast i've ever
been on
i don't know why that is i don't think
our audience is bigger but something
that works and when they get that that
magic moment that of
of people emailing them being like it
worked that was amazing it worked
they're they're
down to do whatever and come back on or
do whatever else and you only need
about 10 20 30 like you don't need a
significant amount right um
20 emails in one day being like i loved
it i love you
is a lot of emails for for most people
it feels like
it feels like a million so mark's name
is a
r c space l o r e look him up on
linkedin and just whatever his recent
thread is just click like comment and be
like just saw you on the podcast so good
yeah saw you on my first million
amazing yeah go go go hammer his
linkedin
comments or something like that
i feel like i can rule the world i know
i could be what i want to
i put my law in it like no days off on a
road less travel never looking back